chalon dans le cas de vénus vous
pourriez être surpris
pour la plupart d'entre nous venus est
simplement l'étoile du soir des
générations d'étudiants en sciences ont
appris qu'elle était la planètes soeurs
de la terre la plus proche de nous après
la lune dans la grèce antique des
observateurs plein d'imagination voyait
en elle aphrodite la déesse de l'amour
et de la beauté
mais en amérique centrale la
civilisation maya identifié venus à coup
kultan le serpent à plumes c'était le
dieu de la guerre à la fois créateur et
destructeur assoiffé de sang coule kahn
exigeait des sacrifices humains et
n'avait rien de romantique
pour les astronomes moderne venus est
une énigme des engins spatiaux
successifs nous ont appris que cette
planète bien quelle est la taille de la
terre ne ressemble pas du tout à cette
dernière la surface de vénus est la plus
chaude de tout le système solaire
venus est un monde qui a mal tourné mais
dont nous avons beaucoup à apprendre
bienvenue sur notre planète soeur un
endroit où il ne ferait pas tellement
bon vivre comparé à ce qui se passe sur
venus no souci écologique paraissent
bien mineur la jumelle de notre planète
souffrent ainsi d'un effet de serre
galopant d'une sévère perte d'ozone d'un
ciel couvert en permanence et d'une
sécheresse générale qui dure depuis 4
milliards d'années
ces conditions épouvantables aurait de
quoi effrayer le commun des mortels mais
elle fascine une foule d'astronomes
surtout depuis que des missions
spatiales se sont approchés de cette
planète
l'impression que j'ai deux venus doper
la mission magellan est celle d'une
planète qui a été entièrement recouverte
d'un blindage de lave à un moment donné
où que l'on regarde sur vénus il ya des
montagnes ou des plaines couverte de
l'art ou des cratères creusés dans la
lave tout et volcanique
les deux planètes
la terre est venus présentent de
nombreuses similitudes leurs distances
par rapport au soleil est très proche
elles ont toutes les deux une atmosphère
mais il ya des différences fondamentales
dans la façon dont chacune évacue sa
chaleur
la majeure partie du carbone vient
constituer une atmosphère très épaisse
et très riches en co2 du coup les
infrarouges ne peuvent pas s'échapper il
fait chaud et sec
c'est difficilement vivable il est fort
probable que jamais un astronaute ne
posant le pied sur vénus et c'est
d'autant plus dommage que cette planète
et pour nous relativement facile a
atteint
placé sur l'orbité voisine de la nôtre
en direction du soleil vénus se
rapprochent périodiquement à 40 millions
de km de la terre alors que la deuxième
planète la plus proche mars n'est jamais
à moins de 55 millions de kilomètres de
nous contrairement à mars vénus est
presque de la même taille que la terre
pour une densité et une masse légèrement
inférieur et ces deux planètes sont
constitués à peu près du même mélange de
rock et de métal
globalement on peut donc bien dire que
vénus et la jumelle de la terre
mais ce sont les détails qui font la
différence à la surface
la température de vénus est d'environ
470 degrés celsius et la pression
atmosphérique et 90 fois supérieure à
celle de la terre
cette atmosphère épaisse et lourde et
composé principalement de dioxyde de
carbone
mais les nuages qu'elles renferment sont
formés d'acide sulfurique concentré ce
que nous appelons communément sur terre
de l'acide de batterie
on comprend dès lors que les
scientifiques n'y voit pas une planète
propices à la vie que faut-il pour qu'un
planète soit habitable et quelles sont
les voies que peuvent emprunter des
formes de vie planétaire venus un
avantage d'être très semblable à la
terre mais elle a évolué dans une autre
direction
c'est en comprenant par quel mystère ces
deux planètes presque jumelles ont pris
des chemins différents que nous pourrons
apprendre beaucoup de choses sur le
fonctionnement des planètes et sur la
rareté des lieux habitables dans
l'univers c'est pourquoi il est
essentiel que nous étudiions venus si
venus nous laisse encore quelque peu
perplexe avant l'ère de la conquête
spatiale
elle était pour l'homme un mystère
complet il faut dire que même avec les
plus gros télescope
on ne voyait pas grand chose les
astronomes savaient que lorsqu'elle
était au plus près notre timide soeur
jumelle détourner sa face éclairée et
pire encore elle était en permanence
recouverte d'une épaisse couche de
nuages
même les données fondamentales comme sa
vitesse de rotation sidéral était
inconnu bref l'observation de la planète
la plus proche de la terre s'avérer
terriblement frustrante
certains en profitèrent pour laisser
libre cours à leur imagination
pendant des années les auteurs de
science-fiction forgèrent à leur guise
un monde que personne ne pouvait
vraiment voir
ainsi en 1951 ray bradbury publia la
pluie une nouvelle ou vénus était
décrite comme une jungle humide
quelques années plus tard isaac asimov
fit de même en mentionnant les océans de
vénus même l'astronome britannique
respecter fred hoyle s'y est mis en 1955
il écrivit une histoire où il imaginait
la planète vénus comme entièrement
recouvertes de pétrole
au cinéma dans un monument kitsch de
1958 queen of outer space la sirène de
hollywood zsa zsa gabor incarna une
scientifique vénusienne qui sauve des
astronautes en perdition fidèle à ce qui
était devenu une tradition
notre planète soeur y étaient
représentées comme un paradis riche en
oxygène des astronomes avaient cependant
détecter la présence de dioxyde de
carbone sur venus dès les années 30 et
avec l'envoi de sonde spatiale
il devint bientôt difficile d'ignorer
cette donnée la science fiction c'est
d'un peu à peu le pas aux faits
scientifiques et la réalité dépasse à
bientôt la fiction
en 1958 des observations par radio
téléscopes montre que vénus et mais un
fort rayonnement de micro ondes
ceci sous-entend qu'il règne sur cette
planète une chaleur extrême mais
certains scientifiques refusent tout net
cette idée la radioastronomie est encore
à l'époque une science récente et il est
plus facile de faire fi de ces prétendus
micro-ondes que d'admettre que la
surface de notre planète soeur est plus
chaude de plusieurs centaines de degrés
que la vallée de la mort la même année
les radioastronomes commence à envoyer
des signaux radar en direction de vénus
et reçoivent en écho l'image grossière
de la surface cachés sous les nuages
en 1962 de meilleures observations
radars permettent de résoudre le mystère
de la rotation de la planète et révèle
qu'elle tourne sur son axe extrêmement
lentement
sa période de rotation sidéral et de 243
jours terrestres
et comparé à toutes les autres planètes
du système solaire
cette rotation s'effectue dans le sens
inverse
aujourd'hui encore les scientifiques
n'ont pas trouvé d'explication à ce
phénomène
toujours en 1962 la sonde marine heures
de survol venus et confirme les
observations radar faites jusqu alors la
surface de la planète est effectivement
très chaude
d'autres survol montre qu'elle est non
seulement d'une chaleur infernale mais
aussi d'une sécheresse absolue dans les
années 70 de nouvelles découvertes sur
l'atmosphère de vénus troubles à nouveau
les chercheurs vu à travers les
télescopes la couche nuageuse présente
un aspect uniforme mais des photos
prises aux ultraviolets par marine r10
en 1973 et pioneer venus en 1978 révèle
plusieurs tâches indistincte mais de
grande taille
après quasiment trois décennies
d'observation les astronomes ne savent
toujours pas avec certitude quel élément
ou composé chimique est responsable de
ces taches foncées
nous ne savons pas non plus pourquoi
l'atmosphère de vénus tourne autour de
la planète beaucoup plus rapidement que
venus ne tourne sur elle même
il faut quatre jours terrestres pour que
l'atmosphère accomplissent une rotation
complète
alors que la planète tourne beaucoup
plus lentement mais nous ne comprenons
pas pourquoi
ironie de la science nous en savons
davantage sur ce qui se trouve sous les
nuages que sur l'atmosphère elle-même il
y a près de 30 ans plusieurs sonde
soviétique ont été parachutés à travers
les multiples couches nuageuses et se
sont posé doucement à la surface de
vénus les sondes vénéra était conçue
pour résister environ une heure avant
que leur circuit ne commence à fondre et
que la machine ne cesse de transmettre
mais pendant ces brèves périodes où elle
était opérationnel
les vénérables on renvoyait sur terre
des photos d'un monde totalement
étranger les premières nous sont
parvenues en 1975 quand les sondes
vénéra 9 et 10 ont transmis des photos
noir et blanc
remarquablement net de plaine rocheuses
desséché en bas de l'image
on distingue le bord de la sonde des
sortes de grosses dalles de pierre
s'étendent jusqu'à l'horizon qui
apparaît fortement incurvé sous cet
angle très large
ça m'évoque un vieux parking
complètement défoncée ce paysage de
blocs plat et fragmentée ressemble
énormément un paysage volcanique et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que c'est on voit
tout ce qu'il y avait au 1er plan
mais dans les coins supérieurs on
aperçoit le ciel et ça me fait toujours
quelque chose de voir un bout de ciel
cette espèce de couvercles rougeoyant et
mystérieux qui s'étend vers l'horizon
c'est le ciel de vénus en 1982 une autre
sonde vénéra nous a offert une photo
couleur du même paysage en bas à gauche
on distingue le pied de la sonde
là encore les roches ressemble à de
grandes dalles et la lumière orangée qui
émane du sol est apparemment fidèles à
la réalité
ceci a été un moment historique de
l'exploration interplanétaire et peut
être le plus grand triomphe des
programmes soviétique de vols spatiaux
inhabités
ce sont les seules photos en couleurs
que l'on n'est jamais prise de la
surface de vénus
une serre est un endroit magique
étudiants son fonctionnement
l'élément clé et son dôme de verre le
verre laisse le rayonnement visible du
soleil pénétrait dans le bâtiment pour
chauffer les plantes
les plantes réémettent cette énergie
sous forme d'onde infrarouge plus longue
que le ver empêche de s'échapper vers
l'extérieur ainsi la serre se réchauffe
même en plein hiver
l'atmosphère qui enveloppent venus
rempli la même fonction que les vitres
d'une serre la fraction du rayonnement
solaire qui traverse les nuages jusqu'à
la surface et réfléchie vers le haut
sous forme d'onde infrarouge plus longue
le dioxyde de carbone contenu dans
l'atmosphère vénusienne étant en grande
partie aux paccots infrarouge ce
rayonnement ne peut le traverser
c'est ainsi que vénus est devenu de plus
en plus chaudes
mais qu'est ce qui a déclenché cet effet
de serre à l'échelle planétaire
nous ne possédons que peu d'indications
fiables sur l'aspect qu'avait venus du
temps de sa jeunesse il y a près de 4
milliards d'années
néanmoins les scientifiques pensent
qu'elle ressemblait alors davantage à la
terre peut-être même comporter tels des
océans
venus est en plus proche du soleil que
la terre le rayonnement solaire est
beaucoup plus important ce qui a
accéléré ce que nous appelons l'effet du
cerf galopant sur la terre une bonne
partie des océans s'évapore dans
l'atmosphère en s'évaporant ils
produisent une grande quantité de vapeur
d'eau or la vapeur d'eau est un puissant
gaz à effet de serre qui réchauffe
encore plus l'atmosphère et plus on
chauffe plus les océans s'évapore c'est
ainsi qu'on arrive à l'effet de serre
galopant plus il fait chaud plus les
océans s'évapore et plus l'effet de
serre et puissant c'est un cercle
vicieux
si cette théorie est exact venus à petit
à petit développer une atmosphère
épaisse et embrumés il y avait de
grandes quantités d'hydrogène et
d'oxygène au début sous forme de vapeur
d'eau puis au fil du temps le
rayonnement du soleil a peu à peu casser
les molécules de vapeur d'eau
plus léger les atomes d'hydrogène ont
dérivé dans l'espace contrairement aux
atomes d'oxygène plus lourds qui sont
restés au même moment
d'innombrables volcan ont craché un
nombre incalculable de mégatonnes de
carbone dans l'air le carbone qui
n'étaient pas déjà oxydé c'est alors
mélangés à ceux qui restent et d'oxygène
jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait presque plus
que du co2 du dioxyde de carbone à
partir de là la situation sur vénus n'a
fait qu'empirer
les gens voient le co2 comme ce gaz
dangereux responsable de l'effet de
serre sur terre alors qu'il n'y en a que
quelques centaines de parties par
million sur notre planète une quantité
infime imagine une planète où il n'y
aurait presque du co2 dans l'atmosphère
en réalité la terre contient
sensiblement la même quantité de carbone
que vénus cependant la plus grande
partie de ce carbone ne se trouve pas
dans l'atmosphère mais est stocké dans
la roche tandis que le reste circulent à
travers l'océan et la biosphère
c'est ce cycle du carbone qui contribue
à refroidir notre planète sur vénus un
tel cycle n'existe pas les volcans ont
expulsé le carbone qui se trouvaient à
l'intérieur de la planète mais sans eau
ce dernier n'a pas pu être précipitée et
enfermé en toute sécurité dans le sous
sol
comme il n'y avait en outre ni océan ni
forme de vie pour l'absorber le carbone
est resté dans l'atmosphère où il
retient la chaleur de façon
remarquablement efficace 4 mai 1989 avec
le lancement de la navette spatiale
atlantis le visage de vénus va bientôt
changer à jamais
une sonde spatiale fait de pièces
détachées provenant d'autres missions
sort doucement de la soute de la navette
mettant le cap sur vénus l'engin nommé
magellan entame un long voyage dans
l'obscurité de l'espace
quinze mois plus tard les responsables
de la mission pousse un soupir de
soulagement lorsque magellan se place en
orbite autour de vénus
après une phase de vérification la sonde
entame sa mission un relevé
topographique de toute la surface de la
planète
magellan va révéler le paysage cacher
grâce un type de radar capable de percer
la couche nuageuse
le radar à synthèse d'ouverture utilise
un traitement intelligent des données
qui simule l'action d'une immense
antenne radar résultat une vue
extrêmement précises du sol cachés sous
les nuages
magellan au père exactement comme prévu
balayant la surface de vénus par bandes
successives et convertissant les données
radar en photo
la mission dure quatre ans pendant
lesquels magellan tourne autour de vénus
en orbite polaire tandis que la planète
effectué lentement sa rotation sidéral
et à chaque passage la sonde prend une
longue bande étroite images radar une
fois toutes les bandes assemblée on
obtient le portrait tant attendu de
vénus toute la planète est visible les
nuages semblent avoir disparu comme par
magie
ces données ont par la suite été
transformé en images 3d numérique dans
une modélisation simulant le survol des
merveilles géologiques de la planète
d'après les responsables qui ont mis au
point ce programme la couleur de la
surface est assez réaliste
seul le ciel a été assombri et les
reliefs du paysage exagéré pour donner
une meilleure vue d'ensemble
chaîne de montagnes accidentées
plateau desséché
dôme de lave et volcans imposant voilà
tout ce que l'oeil du radar de magellan
nous a dévoilé magellan a aussi
découvert environ un millier de cratère
comme ceux qui émaillent la lune
ces trous déchiquetés ont été creusés
par des météorites s'écrasant à la
surface mais certaines caractéristiques
de ces impacts météoritiques ont retenu
l'attention des scientifiques des
aspects intéressants de ce millier de
cratères et qu en dessous d'une certaine
taille
quelques kilomètres de diamètre on en
trouve très peu contrairement à ce qu'on
a pu observer sur la chaîne survenue
l'atmosphère très dense agit comme un
filtre et consume les météorites de
petite taille avant qu'il ne s'écrase à
la surface et forment un petit cratère
un des outils les plus efficaces à la
disposition des astronomes pour évaluer
l'âge de la surface d'une planète et le
nombre et la distribution des cratères
dus à des impacts
les scientifiques peuvent en effet
calculé le nombre de cratères censé se
former pendant une période géologique
données en général les zones qui
présentent un nombre plus élevé de
cratères sont plus anciennes que celles
où ce nombre est moins élevé sur la lune
ces régions voisines montre des densités
de cratères très différentes
la zone criblé sur la droite a été
bombardé par des impacts de météorites
il y a près de 4 milliards d'années la
plaine lice sur la gauche s'est formée
lorsque la lave a rempli un bassin peu
profond il y a environ un milliard
d'années après la fin du bombardement
météoritique les quelques rares cratère
dans la plaine de lave se sont formés
encore plus tard
les scientifiques du programme magellan
étaient impatients d'appliquer cette
technique de datation à la surface
vénusienne mais ils se sont trouvés
confrontés à la seule possibilité qu'il
n'avait pas envisagé la densité de
cratère était la même sur toute la
surface de la planète ce qui était
d'autant plus étrange qui ne dénombrait
pas tant de cratères que cela la surface
de vénus est plus importante que la
surface des terres émergées sur notre
planète
compte tenu de cela un millier de
cratères d'impact est un chiffre
relativement peu élevé cela nous indique
que la surface de vénus et plutôt jeunes
vraisemblablement moins d'un milliard
d'années peut-être un demi milliard une
autre observation intéressante
concernant ce millier de cratères et que
la plupart semblent assez récent ils ont
l'air de s'être formé au cours des 10 ou
20 dernières années
alors qu'on s'attendait à trouver des
cratères présentant divers état de
dégradation si certains processus avait
eu lieu
érosion enfouissement sur des
écoulements volcaniques
certains cratères devrait être
partiellement détruits et d'autres
devraient avoir l'air plus récents or
presque tous semblent très récent
et si cela suggère qu'au cours du
dernier milliards d'années tous les
cratères plus anciens ont été arasées
venus est une planète dont le moteur
interne semble en surchauffe pourtant si
sa surface est couverte de volcans de
toutes tailles
aucun pour autant que nous puissions en
juger des en éruption
la plupart des cratères n'ont pas été
recouvert par des écoulements de lave et
il ne présente aucun signe d'activité
ce qui explique pourquoi les
scientifiques considèrent venus comme un
cas d'arrêt de croissance planétaire
oh
il
outre les défis technologiques et
scientifiques qu'elle suppose
l'exploration spatiale pose un problème
terminologique quel nom donner à tous
ces reliefs découvert récemment
les premières cartes de vénus établi par
radar dans les années 60 était très
rudimentaire seules trois régions se
détachait alpha et bêta était
manifestement des points névralgiques
mais il restait à déterminer de quelle
sorte est le seul relief qui semble est
identifiable était une chaîne
montagneuse les radioastronomes l'a
baptisé à maxwell
d'après le grand physicien écossais
james clark maxwell dont les travaux sur
les radiations menèrent à l'invention du
radar et de la transmission radio depuis
une commission internationale à décréter
que les noms de lieux sur vénus
devraient tous évoqué une femme après
tout cette planète est la seule à porter
le nom d'une déesse
c'est ainsi qu'aujourd'hui les monts
maxwell se dresse au dessus d'ishtar
terra et surplombe les plaines de leda
et au delà aphrodite terra et la fosse
de diana
les noms des reliefs vénusien route
hommage des femmes célèbres allant dave
à la déesse de la fertilité babylonienne
en passant par hélène de troie en plein
coeur des monts maxwell par exemple se
trouvent le cratère cléopâtre james
clark maxwell était un pur produit de
l'ère victorienne
on peut se demander comment ce gentleman
et professeur de physique du 19e siècle
aurait réagi à l'idée d'être le seul
homme sur une planète envahi de femmes
et de ds
à la fin des années soixante dix
l'émission pioneer venus ont quelque peu
affiné notre vision de vénus pioneer a
montré que la surface de la planète
était une plaine assez monotone un peu
comme le plancher océanique
la différence étant que sur vénus il n'y
avait pas deux continents en fait les
mots maxwell sont sa seule et unique
chaîne montagneuse la région de hautes
terres ishtar tera est elle aussi unique
en son genre un peu comme si venus avait
sa propre version du tibet sans
l'équivalent de l'asie ou de tout autre
continent d'ailleurs les cartes radars à
faible résolution de pioneer venus
n'étant pas assez bonnes pour en
expliquer les raisons
les scientifiques ont conçu un engin
spatial capable de cartographier venus
avec une précision extrême
c'est ainsi que la mission magellan a
permis d'obtenir des photos bien plus
nette des volcans et des cratères
ce qui nous ramène au problème du nombre
de cratères vénusien à la grande
surprise des astronomes magellan a
révélé que les cratères étaient
distribués uniformément sur la surface
de la planète
cette observation fondamentale
signifiait que les zones creusées de
cratères avaient toutes le même âge et
aux logiques
un âge qui s'avéra étonnamment jeunes la
mission magellan a suggéré une
possibilité surprenante le manteau de
vénus c'est littéralement retourné et sa
surface a été complètement recouverte de
ce matériau volcanique à peu près d'un
seul coup il y a environ un demi
milliard d'années en effet la
distribution des cratères à la surface
leur nombre et leur emplacement pro
clairement qu'il y a une activité
importante
un demi milliard d'années ne représente
que 10% de l'âge totale de la planète
exception faite de quelques rares
impacts météoritiques il ne s'est rien
passé récemment venus semble en sommeil
du moins au premier coup d'oeil
mais après un examen plus approfondi
les scientifiques pensent avoir repéré
des indices d'activité volcanique qui
aurait eu lieu au cours des 100 derniers
millions d'années
autant dire hier sur le plan géologique
il est clair que l'activité volcanique
continue aujourd'hui il ya quelques
raisons de le penser et la meilleure se
trouve non pas à la surface de la
planète mais dans son atmosphère sur
terre aussi on a des émissions de soufre
et de dioxyde de carbone sur les volcans
hawaïen on est saisi par l'odeur de
soufre c'est la même chose sur vénus
actuellement il y a bien trop de soufre
dans l'atmosphère pour que les volcans
soit passif on a fait des modélisations
de ce qui arriverait au nuage
si toute activité volcanique
s'arrêtaient il disparaîtrait ils
dépendent du soufre émis par les volcans
il est clair qu'on a une source active
de souffre et se sont forcément les
volcans trouvé que les volcans sont
toujours actives sur vénus est une autre
affaire
les scientifiques sont à l'affût de
vastes écoulement de lave qui change de
forme ou mieux encore d'un grand panache
volcanique
la preuve manifeste d'un volcanisme
vénusien serait une image nette d'un
cône fumant mais les astronomes ignore 6
en obtiendront un jour une au final ils
sont confrontés à un paradoxe
fondamental venus à une surface jeunes
sur le plan géologique est hérissé de
volcans et pourtant il ne semble y avoir
aucune activité volcanique
alors que se passe-t-il
il y a deux écoles pour la première
venus a été pendant une longue période
une planète très agitée avec d'immenses
écoulements dans l'avs est une des
formations intenses entraînant la
formation de montagne et de hautes
terres et dans un intervalle de temps
relativement bref 100 millions d'années
peut-être sa surface s'est stabilisé et
les déformations se sont arrêtés à
l'exception de quelques zones limitées
où l'activité volcanique s'est concentré
pour l'autre école de pensée tout cela
s'est produit il ya 500 millions
d'années mais c'est aussi répété
plusieurs fois depuis
il y aurait donc des périodes d'activité
intense des formations éruption
projection de magma entrecoupé de
longues périodes de calme
nous ne saurons quelle école est la
bonne
que lorsque nous aurons compris le
fonctionnement interne de vénus la terre
et vénus présentent de nombreuses
similitudes mais il ya une différence
essentielle dans la façon dont les deux
planètes évacuent leur chaleur
sur terre cela se fait par le processus
de la tectonique des plaques
les plaques sont en mouvement constant
et ouvre des zones où le magma peut
remonter librement à la surface sur le
plancher océanique
elle s'enfonce les unes sur les autres
ce qui donne continuellement des
tremblements de terre et génère de
nouveaux volcans sur vénus par contre on
n'a vu aucun indice d'une activité
constante de ce type c'est davantage
épisodique dans un passé géologique
récents venus semble avoir connu une
période de forte activité qui s'est
arrêtée depuis les spécialistes qui
conçoivent des modèles de l'intérieur de
venus pour tenter de trouver une
explication pense que nous sommes en
présence d'un cycle d'une très longue
durée
par conséquent dans un avenir plus ou
moins proche
il y aura vraisemblablement une autre
période de forte activité à la surface
de vénus qui aura pour effet d'évacuer
une énorme quantité de chaleur lors d'un
grand cataclysme
on a de bonnes raisons de le penser
parce qu'une des différences
fondamentales entre vénus et la terre et
la sécheresse extrême de la première une
sécheresse qui affecte certainement tout
le fonctionnement de la planète y
compris sa dynamique interne
les chercheurs ont conçu des modèles de
la convection thermique interne et de la
tectonique des plaques sur terre et se
sont demandés et si on a séché tout en
levant toute l'eau et au lieu d'avoir
une belle mécanique tectoniques bien
huilé comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
quand on assèche la planète le moteur se
grippe par manque de lubrifiants et la
tectonique des plaques s'arrête pas
définitivement
elle s'arrête temporairement parce que
la chaleur doit être évacuée dans les
entrailles de vénus couve une nouvelle
quantité de chaleur qui augmente et
finira un jour par être expulsé à la
surface
il n'y a actuellement aucune mission
interplanétaire sur vénus mais cela
n'empêche pas les scientifiques de
réfléchir à la prochaine vague
d'exploration devrions-nous étudier
notre planète soeur avec un nouveau type
de radar ou peut être avec une sonde
perfectionner sensibles à la chaleur
et pourquoi pas un module résistant
capable de creuser le sol bizarrement
une méthode tout à fait envisageable
serait d'explorer venus en utilisant des
ballons
retourneront nous un jour sur vénus les
astronomes ne manque pas de faire
remarquer qu'aujourd'hui la majeure
partie du budget alloué aux explorations
est consacrée à mars
pourtant d'autres phénomènes étranges à
découvrir et d'autres réponses aux
questions que nous nous posons nous
attendent sur notre planète jumelle
alors quelles seront les priorités des
prochaines missions sur vénus un
objectif majeur est la recherche du
moindre signe d'activité à sa surface
les chercheurs veulent mesurer la
quantité de chaleur évacués de
l'intérieur vers l'extérieur de la
planète ce qu'on appelle en langage
scientifique
le flux de chaleur c'est le plus
important car si on connaissait ce flux
de chaleur
on pourrait distinguer le
refroidissement graduelle de la planète
qui a plus ou moins tout arrêter à sa
surface il y à 500 millions d'années des
modèles épisodique qui disent que vénus
connaîtra à l'avenir de nouvelles phases
de violence si le flux de chaleur de
vénus est trop bas pour évacuer toute la
chaleur générée à l'intérieur cela
signifie qu'elle se réchauffe et si elle
se réchauffe
nous allons vers une catastrophe mais si
ce flux est assez élevé pour évacuer
toute la chaleur interne alors ce que
nous voyons à la surface de vénus ne
changera pas actuellement tout semble
indiquer que ce flux est bas par
conséquent l'intérieur de la planète est
certainement en phase de réchauffement
est un peu tôt pour l'affirmer mais les
recherches vont dans cette direction
pour confirmer cette hypothèse il
faudrait une preuve irréfutable un
volcan en phase d'éruption
mais les éruptions sont difficiles à
repérer par radar
pour david greene spoon la solution
serait d'envoyer sur vénus une mission
équipé d'une caméra à infrarouge sur
terre quand on survole hawaï la nuit
avec un détecteur infrarouge
on distingue les vagues de chaleur
dégagée par les écoulements actifs on
pourrait faire pareil en orbite autour
de vénus pour chercher des écoulements
volcanique actifs grâce à leur signature
calorifique
donc il nous reste des choses à essayer
pour trouver des indices de volcanisme
sur vénus il y aurait peut-être un moyen
de détecter les écoulements de l'avs
sans quitter la terre diverses
techniques expérimentales ont déjà été
testés dans des observatoires radio en
amérique du nord
les astronomes ont fait du chemin depuis
qu'ils ont commencé à dresser les
premières cartes de vénus dans les
années 60
au bon vieux temps de la radar
astronomie une seule et même antenne
envoyez-les ondes radio vers son
objectif dans ce cas venus et recevait
son écot le nombre d'informations que
l'on pouvait en tirer était restreint
parce qu'on était limité à une seule
antenne même de grande taille
aujourd'hui on peut envoyer londres
radio et recevoir son écot simultanément
sur plus d'un télescope comme sur les
sites d'arecibo sur l'île de porto rico
et celui de green bank en virginie
occidentale qui sont équipés d'immenses
radiotélescope ces récepteurs sont
capables de combiner leurs informations
de manière à fournir des données
beaucoup plus précise et détaillée sur
la surface de vénus ou d'ailleurs que ne
le ferait un seul récepteur
ainsi nous pouvons étudier la surface de
vénus à volonté distinguer des détails à
l'échelle du kilomètre et voir s'il y a
eu une éruption majeure depuis l'année
dernière où ces dix dernières années
malgré ces progrès spectaculaires les
grandes questions des scientifiques
resteront sans réponse tant qu'un engin
spatial ne sera pas retourner sur vénus
et tous les chercheurs ont un projet ou
un programme particulier qu'ils
aimeraient voir mener à bien sûr notre
mystérieuse voisine
s'il ne tenait qu'à moi et si ça ne
dépendait pas de questions financières
comme ça l'est toujours
qu'est ce que j'aimerais savoir sur
vénus j'aimerais voir un échantillon du
sol pour l'étudier en laboratoire on
connaîtrait la chimie de ce matériau et
son âge on pourrait en tirer des
conclusions géologique
ce serait une avancée cruciale pour
comprendre toute l'histoire de sa
surface
un autre moyen de s'attaquer aux
mystères de vénus serait de mettre en
place ce qu'on appelle un réseau
sismique à sa surface
mais cela ne serait pas une tâche aisée
car il faudrait placés à des endroits
stratégiques des sismographes comme ceux
qui sont utilisés dans les stations de
surveillance sismique sur la terre ce
serait très intéressant car cette
planète de la taille de la terre a
forcément une activité sismique
avec un tel réseau on pourrait sonder
l'intérieur de vénus tout comme on le
fait sur terre et élargir nos
connaissances sur la structure interne
et le fonctionnement de la terre en tant
que planète
c'est pour cela il nous faudrait des
machines capables de survivre sur vénus
pas juste pendant une heure comme les
sondes vénéra mais pendant des mois
cela implique une technologie dont on ne
dispose pas encore actuellement mais des
gens très intelligents il travailla
j'espère voir cela un jour c'est un de
mes grands espoirs les ingénieurs
cherchent des moyens d'envoyer des
instruments sur vénus en réduisant leur
exposition conditions impitoyables qui
règne à sa surface
une solution inédite serait d'envoyer un
engin qui ne se poserait pas et ne se
placerait pas non plus en orbite mais
flotterait dans l'atmosphère
ce concept étonnant implique
l'utilisation d'un ballon sonde baptisé
héros bottes il arriverait sur vénus via
un vaisseau spatial qui le larguerait
dans l'atmosphère de la planète et
serait ensuite capable de monter et
descendre sur commande tout en dérivant
au tour de la planète en utilisant les
vents vénusien la température à la
surface étant trop élevé pour la plupart
de nos instruments les 'robots' ne
descendraient que pendant un laps de
temps limité pour prendre des mesures
avant de remonter dans l'atmosphère
elles se refroidir un héros bottes
pourraient prendre des photos aériennes
de vénus qui serait très différent des
images radars actuels et permettrait de
repérer plus efficacement les panaches
de volcans en activité
il pourrait en outre effectuer un autre
type d'observation qui aurait peu de
chances de donner des résultats mais qui
cependant en vaudrait la peine pour
david greene spoon jeu nourrit toujours
l'espoir que les nuages de vénus abrite
une forme de vie nous n'avons pas assez
bien exploré cette planète pour exclure
cette possibilité
la température et la pression reste dans
une fourchette ou la vie telle qu'on la
connaît pourrait exister tant qu'on a un
environnement dynamique le flux
l'énergie et les transformations sont
importants et où de nombreuses
caractéristiques restent encore
inexpliquées et inexplorée on ne peut
pas décréter qu'il n'y a pas de vie et
qu'il n'y en a jamais eu
mais outre la question de la vie sur
vénus son exploration nous offrirait des
indices essentiels sur l'évolution ou
l'absence d'évolution des environnements
habitable des planètes
nous devons explorer de façon
approfondie
sylvain voulons percer le mystère de la
vie dans l'univers
malheureusement nous ignorons quelles et
l'ensemble des facteurs qui déterminent
l'évolution d'une planète qui sait ce
qui fait pencher la balance entre le
chaud et le froid l'humidité le sec
l'éventail des forces qui façonnent les
planètes s'avère plus large et plus
complexe que nous ne l'avions imaginé
sonder d'autres mondes est notre
meilleur espoir de comprendre la terre
et grâce à venus notamment
nous avons déjà pas mal appris
venus peut apprendre aux terriens un
certain nombre de choses sur
l'environnement elle nous a ainsi
enseigné que le climat d'une planète est
fragile et que les planètes évolue
naturellement vers des conditions
hostiles à la vie en étudiants venus
nous pourrions élargir nos connaissances
sur le fonctionnement de la terre ainsi
il y à quelques dizaines d'années
les scientifiques se sont aperçus que la
couche d'ozone qui protège la terre des
rayons ultraviolets nocifs s'amenuisait
au dessus de l'antarctique depuis le
fameux trou de la couche d'ozone est
devenu un problème écologique
préoccupant or à peu près à la même
époque tout à fait par hasard
les astronomes ont constaté une pénurie
d'oxygène dans la haute atmosphère de
vénus
il devrait y avoir beaucoup d'oxygène
parce que l'atmosphère est constitué
principalement de co2 et que les
ultraviolets dissocie les molécules de
co2 ce qui libère divers composants
gazeux à base d'oxygène mais là ils ne
sont pas aussi abondant qu'il devrait
l'être
une des explications possibles a été
fourni par la présence de chlore dans la
haute atmosphère de vénus
il se trouve que le chlore détruit les
molécules d'oxygène un scientifique a eu
l'idée brillante de se dire le chlore
détruire les molécules d'oxygène dans
l'atmosphère de vénus est ce aussi ce
qui se passe sur terre
c'est ce qui a conduit directement à la
découverte du problème de la couche
d'ozone
nous avons introduit des produits
chimiques les chlorofluorocarbures qui
finissent par atteindre notre
stratosphère où leurs molécules sont
cassées par les ultraviolets est aussi
aujourd'hui que la dissociation des
molécules de chlore et de fluor
provoquent des dégâts épouvantables dans
la couche d'ozone
voilà donc un exemple extraordinaire de
la façon dont l'exploration d'une
planète ont motivé au départ par notre
seul désir d'en savoir plus sur le
système solaire nous a sensibilisés à ce
qui se passe sur terre et aux dégâts que
nous faisons subir à notre propre
planète
venus pourrait également nous éclairer
sur un autre problème écologique
l'effet de serre depuis la révolution
industrielle la combustion de carburants
fossiles a libéré des milliards de
tonnes de carbone dans l'atmosphère
tôt ou tard nous en subiront les
conséquences
mais les spécialistes des phénomènes
atmosphériques ont du mal à prédire
quand exactement
malgré l'importance cruciale de ces
questions pour les générations futures
on ne sait toujours pas si le
réchauffement climatique a déjà commencé
et personne n'est tombé d'accord sur
l'ampleur qu'il pourrait prendre
ce débat contradictoire autour du
réchauffement de la planète est
insoluble en partie parce que nos
ordinateurs ne peuvent pas simuler
toutes les manifestations du système
climatique
étonnamment complexe de la terre l'étude
d'une planète comme vénus que nous
apprendre beaucoup de choses sur le
fonctionnement des climats sur les
planètes et sur la modélisation de ces
climats on a conçu des modèles pour
tenter de prévoir l'évolution du climat
terrestre
si nous continuons à injecter du co2
dans l'atmosphère en combien de temps la
température va t-elle se réchauffer et
que se passera-t-il si nous doublons la
quantité de co2 mais ces modèles ne sont
pas forcément fiables
il ya tout un débat à ce sujet mais
c'est une question extrêmement complexe
nous aimerions bien trouver un moyen de
mettre ses prévisions à l'épreuve
si on avait une planètes comme la terre
mais beaucoup plus riches en co2 on
pourrait faire des prévisions et
éprouver leur exactitude venus nous
offre justement cette opportunité avant
l'ère spatiale
nous avions de bonnes raisons de croire
que vénus était comme la terre les deux
planètes se trouve dans la même partie
du système solaire elles sont composées
approximativement du même mélange de
matériaux
venus est plus petite que la terre de
seulement 10% et n'a qu'une lune de
moins peut-on vraiment parler de
différences
mais vénus et pourtant radicalement
différente de la terre son atmosphère et
sa surface n'ont rien à voir avec leurs
équivalents terrestre bien que nous
n'ayons pas trouvé une seule bonne
raison qui explique cet état de choses
si la terre avait été un peu plus petit
serait elle devenue une fournaise à
l'image de vénus s à distance un peu
plus grande au soleil sa rotation plus
rapide où la présence d'une lune de
grande taille qui a conduit notre
planète sur un chemin évolutif aussi
opposés compte tenu de notre ignorance
actuelle il nous est impossible de
trancher venus reste une énigme couverte
de l'avait enveloppé de nuages et en
attendant qu elles nous apprennent autre
chose
l'étoile du soir donne déjà une
magnifique leçon d'humilité à tous ceux
qui tentent de percer les secrets des
planètes